liberals getting called out for their
selective outrage on crime for example
10 year old boy was shot and killed in
new york city
disturbing video shows the suspect
opening fire into a house
bullets struck two people inside and
killed that child
but so far there's been deafening
silence from the likes of
aoc and black lives matter apparently
aoc is too busy endorsing new york city
mayoral candidate maya wiley
who wants to defund the police but has
private security
guarding her block while he says her
partner
is the one who's paying for it and his
crime surges across the country
americans are fighting against
defunding police residents in
minneapolis are suing the city
and the mayor for cutting the police
budget and failing to keep them safe
and the parents in atlanta are suing
city leaders after their eight-year-old
daughter was shot and killed
during violent protests last year
so greg you know you read these stories
about these defund the police people and
then it turns out they're big private
security people
what say you well it
it's kind of a relief that we're doing
these stories because we've been doing
them
consistently for quite a while we when
the when the
crime rate spiked and the riots in the
summertime
we were the ones talking about this
stuff when
other the legacy media and the democrats
didn't want to talk about it
all of these all of these problems have
been going on forever
but now they're deciding to to focus on
it because it's going to hurt them
politically
which is very sad they were happy uh if
you remember last year when cnn their
their prime time anchors were mocking
ooh the right wing for being upset about
crime do you remember we played that
side of
of uh um lemon in in cuomo mocking
people
who were who were actually concerned
about black on black crime
and then lemon a couple weeks later goes
hey uh this could hurt biden so we
better do something about the crime
how bloodless is that to only care about
suffering if it's politically contingent
um all of these problems come from two
sources
uh that have been going on for decades a
rejection of law and order as something
that is lacking in compassion
we talked about that with the border too
so so if you believe in law and order
you are a cold heartless person if you
defend
law and order the second part of that is
that you're racist so
uh they i the left identifies the
problem
and then makes it unsolvable because
every solution
is somehow going to be going to be
racist
so now you what you end up as a result
is you have the defunding movement
and you've got incinerated uh cities
and all of this is caused by a media
well it's
it's assisted by a media generate
generated narrative
which said that cops were hunting blacks
and when you end up looking at the
statistics it's a huge lie that led to
the ferguson effect
cops pulling back leading to the riots
of the two dozen or so shocking
shooting deaths of unarmed human beings
half of them more than half were white
the percentages were higher were white
based on police stops
so a lot of this suffering and killing
was completely completely based on
on truths and the media is not admitting
that the defund the police movement has
backfired geraldo here in new york the
mayoral race
the guy who's way ahead black democrat
running on restoring law and order to
new york city and he's ahead in the
polls
eric adams great guy i've known him for
years actually made a couple of speeches
on his behalf
former nypd captain all about law and
order
he hid it exactly right going back to my
wiley
and the uh private police force it's a
it's due as i say not as i do i mean
that's pretty typical
but i want to say something a little
bigger i think that black lives matter
is the most utterly
failed movement in in recent times you
have a movement that
that pretends to care about black lives
when in fact as you demonstrated very
graphically
at the top of the show jesse the black
life they care about is the one taken by
the cop
right if the cop is not involved they
are not involved
and the vast majority of the of the
casualties
in the in the black and brown
neighborhoods
are caused by other black and brown
people
black on black violence is raging out of
control
uh it is the uh it is the civil rights
issue of our time
uh it is if we don't address it
we're losing a generation of young black
men from coast to coast and the
perpetrators
our other young black man that guy
firing that weapon
into that apartment killing that child
is infuriating
and where is the leadership that we've
been listening to
for the entire year where are they well
maybe
joe biden can deputize kamala harris to
look into the root causes
katie yeah well then nothing will get
done unfortunately but joe biden could
ask his justice department to do
something like operation legend like the
trump administration did where their
federal government partnered with local
authorities to solve murders of children
in these communities especially in
places where local officials have tried
to defund the police and they don't have
the resources
resources to do this but the idea that
these politicians
continue to want to defund the police
while also taking away everybody's
second amendment rights to defend
themselves against violent criminals
it's not just hypocritical it's elitist
and so they are willing to isolate
themselves with private security that
they can afford through political means
and donations
while forcing everybody else to be
victim victims
of crime and violence that is a result
of their direct decision-making and
policies to defund the police i mean
it's an absolutely despicable elitist
way of governing and we've seen this all
over the country and when it comes to
how does this keep happening how is it
that little kids are being shot in their
homes or in road rage incidents
well in places like la in san francisco
in
new york in washington state you have
all of these da's who are unwilling to
actually prosecute criminals
violent criminals they are letting them
out of jail and this is not just a fluke
this is an
ideology promoted by black lives matter
they say that they're all about justice
but justice for who
for the criminals who are willing to
commit violent acts against children
what about the victims of these crimes
the mothers whose children are not dead
as a result of these da's letting people
out of
out of jail and they go and recommit
crimes that is their responsibility but
it's not just
a mistake this is an ideology that they
actually believe in
and now average families are having to
sue
cities and states for these policies
that have left people dead and those
lawsuits usually don't
go very well so it's just it's sad and
then you had the situation
in philadelphia where krasner one of
those district
attorneys he actually got reelected by a
lot
pathetic so there is there's that but
back to the on the new york
race so it's interesting because maya
wiley she worked
for the de blasio administration now it
is almost universally agreed to
that mayor de blasio is the worst mayor
in the history
of this city so if i were one of her
opponents i would be trying to tie
that back to them i do think that defund
the police movement is now a liability
for democrats
for so long that democrats and and the
right does this too
when when you ignore your moderates it's
to your apparel because
they swing this they could go back and
forth if maya
wiley loses which i i don't know exactly
what will happen there's ranked choice
voting for the first time in new york
city
this is an experiment that we're all
going to have to see how how it works
but i do think eric adams is going to
win she is the political guinea pig for
the progressive left
and if people like abigail spamberger
the congresswoman from virginia who said
we almost didn't keep the majority in
the house of representatives in 2020
because of all of this radical leftist
rhetoric then maybe they'll pay
attention to somebody like maya losing
there's ranked voting now in new york
city the first time
that sounds confusing i'm gonna have a
problem with my ballot
it's pretty ranked bring one of your
kids in
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else